Today's episode is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many years ago, when I was a child, my mother told me a family story. It had to do with her brother, my uncle. He was an extremely creative man with varied interests in books and music and art. He could also be a little, how shall I put this, disorganized. My uncle was the kind of person who was always ready to reminisce and he was an amazing storyteller. He could spin the tiniest events into funny stories that had you laughing until you cried. Anyway
今天的节目由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。这里是《隐藏的大脑》(Hidden Brain)。我是 Shankar Vedantam。很多年前，我还是个孩子的时候，母亲给我讲过一个家庭故事。故事的主角是她的哥哥，也就是我的舅舅。他是一个非常有创造力的人，对书籍、音乐和艺术有着广泛的兴趣。但他也有点，我该怎么说呢，不拘小节。我舅舅是那种随时准备追忆往事的人，他也是一位了不起的讲故事高手。他能把最琐碎的小事编成有趣的故事，让你笑到流泪。总之
the story my mother told me had to do with my uncle's wedding day. On his way to the wedding venue, my uncle suddenly remembered he had forgotten to invite a dear friend and fellow storyteller, his barber. So he took a detour and went to the barber shop to make sure his friend came to the wedding. When he got to the shop, the barber was busy with his customers and asked my uncle to wait while he finished. My uncle happily settled down and he and the barber traded funny stories as the scissors went snip snip. All this time of course, the guests at the wedding
母亲讲的那个故事与舅舅的婚礼有关。在去婚礼现场的路上，舅舅突然想起他忘了邀请一位挚友，也是一位讲故事的好手——他的理发师。于是他绕道去了理发店，确保他的朋友能来参加婚礼。当他到达店里时，理发师正忙着招待顾客，便让舅舅等他忙完。舅舅愉快地坐了下来，随着剪刀“咔嚓咔嚓”的声音，他和理发师交换着有趣的故事。当然，在这段时间里，婚礼上的宾客
and the prospective bride were getting increasingly alarmed. Had something happened to the groom? Had he gotten cold feet? Was the marriage called off? When my uncle finally showed up, his barber triumphantly in tow, he had no idea why everyone was upset. I've always loved that story because it perfectly captured my uncle's attitude toward life. Live in the moment, be present. Deadlines and appointments can wait. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the world of family stories, how these stories shape who we become, and the fascinating signs that demonstrates why telling certain kinds of stories can make us happier, healthier,
和准新娘越来越焦急。新郎出事了吗？他临阵退缩了吗？婚礼取消了吗？当舅舅终于带着他那理发师朋友凯旋而归时，他完全不知道大家为什么那么生气。我一直很喜欢这个故事，因为它完美地捕捉到了舅舅的人生态度。活在当下，身临其境。截止日期和预约都可以等。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探索家庭故事的世界，了解这些故事如何塑造我们，以及一些迷人的迹象，证明为什么讲述某些类型的故事能让我们更快乐、更健康，
and better people. Cultures around the world have occasions that are designed for people to gather, chat, and reminisce. This can happen on birthdays, on anniversaries, and at funerals. Family members remind each other about the ties that bind them together. Disputes break out over half-remembered events from decades ago. At Emory University, psychologist Robin Fivush studies the psychological effects these stories can have on our lives. Robin Fivush, welcome to Hidden Brain.
并成为更好的人。世界各地的文化都有让人们聚在一起、聊天和追忆往事的场合。这可能发生在生日、周年纪念日和葬礼上。家庭成员互相提醒着将他们联系在一起的纽带。关于几十年前半模糊的往事，争论时有发生。在埃默里大学，心理学家 Robin Fivush 研究了这些故事对我们生活产生的心理影响。Robin Fivush，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you. I'm so privileged to be here. I really am looking forward to this interview. Robin, when you were very young, your family was struck by two terrible tragedies more or less simultaneously. It changed the course of your life. Can you tell me what happened? Well, my father died when I was quite young and my mother was in a very, very bad car accident. She went through the passenger side window with the windshield, was thrown out of the car, and she was actually in a coma for six weeks. So she was in a coma when my father died. Oh my God. She had a lot of bodily fractures, as you might imagine. She was in a body cast, but she also had
谢谢。我很荣幸能来到这里。我真的很期待这次采访。Robin，当你还很小的时候，你的家庭几乎同时遭遇了两场可怕的悲剧。这改变了你的人生轨迹。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？嗯，我父亲在我很小的时候就去世了，我母亲出了一场非常非常严重的车祸。她从副驾驶座的窗户飞了出去，穿过了挡风玻璃，被甩出了车外，她实际上昏迷了六周。所以在我父亲去世时，她正处于昏迷状态。天哪。正如你所想象的那样，她全身多处骨折。她全身打着石膏，但她也受到了
a lot of cognitive damage and was essentially in and out of hospitals for a number of years. So my grandparents raised me and my sister for most of my childhood. And during that time, we spent, frankly, quite a lot of time in hospital waiting rooms and not spending time doing many of the typical activities of childhood. If I could ask you what happened to your dad, how did he come to pass away at an early age?
很多认知损伤，基本上有几年时间都在医院进进出出。所以我的童年大部分时间是由祖父母抚养我和姐姐长大的。在那段时间里，坦白说，我们花了很多时间在医院的候诊室里，并没有花时间去做许多典型的童年活动。如果我能问你父亲发生了什么事，他是怎么在早年去世的？
He died of cancer. I see. And how old were you at the time, Robin? I was three years old. Oh, so you were very young. You probably have very few memories of your dad. You know, it's interesting. It's one of the things that actually got me interested in studying memory is I was very
他死于癌症。我明白了。Robin，那时你多大？我三岁。哦，那你当时很小。你可能对父亲的记忆很少。你知道，这很有趣。这实际上是我对研究记忆产生兴趣的原因之一，因为我当时非常
young and most people can't remember things that happened before they were about three or three and a half. That's a very strong research finding. When you ask adults to recall their earliest childhood memories, they almost never remember anything that happened before they were three. But I have this unfortunate marker in my childhood. I know if I remember my father, it had to be something that happened before I was three. And I actually have two memories of my father.
年幼，大多数人无法记住三岁或三岁半之前发生的事情。这是一个非常强有力的研究发现。当你要求成年人回忆他们最早的童年记忆时，他们几乎从不记得三岁之前发生的任何事情。但我童年里有这个不幸的标记。我知道如果我记得我父亲，那一定是我三岁之前发生的事情。我实际上有两个关于我父亲的记忆。
They're very strong images and sense perceptions of being with him. Can you tell me what those two memories are? One is actually we were visiting caverns, underground caverns in upstate New York. I believe they're called house caverns. My sister is about three years older than me. This is my mother, my father, and I was on my father's shoulders. And I remember the feeling of being on his shoulders. And then suddenly things going very dark because they turned off all the lights in the cave. And feeling safe. And that's it. That's the whole memory.
它们是非常强烈的图像和感官知觉，是关于和他在一起的。你能告诉我那两个记忆是什么吗？一个是实际上我们当时正在参观洞穴，纽约州北部的地下洞穴。我相信它们被称为“房屋洞穴”。我姐姐比我大三岁左右。当时是我母亲、我父亲，我坐在我父亲的肩膀上。我记得坐在他肩膀上的感觉。然后突然间，因为他们关掉了洞穴里所有的灯，一切变得非常黑暗。但我感到很安全。就是这样。这就是全部记忆。
And you felt safe of course because you were sitting on your father's shoulders. I was sitting on his shoulders. And of course, obviously that's a super meaningful memory to me because I have so little of my father, so little of that security of having my father there to protect me and support me. The other memory is much more mundane. I remember him giving me a bath. The twin tragedies of her father's death and her mother's injuries devastated the family. Of course, Robin was too young to fully understand what was happening.
你感到安全当然是因为你坐在父亲的肩膀上。我坐在他的肩膀上。当然，这对我来说是一个非常有意义的记忆，因为我对父亲的记忆太少了，那种有父亲保护和支持我的安全感太少了。另一个记忆就平凡多了。我记得他给我洗澡。她父亲去世和母亲受伤的双重悲剧摧毁了这个家庭。当然，Robin 当时太小，无法完全理解发生了什么。
I'm sure it was devastating. You know, I was three. So my experience was just my life was yanked out, but I didn't have a full cognitive understanding of the context and what was going on. So my memories from that period are very fragmentary and really not very coherent in the way and frankly my family, their way of dealing with it was just never to talk about it. I mean I can imagine at one level this must have been so painful and even recollecting these events must have been so painful and perhaps they were worried that you were very small and talking to you about something that was painful
我敢肯定那一定是毁灭性的。你知道，我当时三岁。所以我的经历只是我的生活被连根拔起，但我对背景和正在发生的事情没有完全的认知理解。所以我那个时期的记忆非常零碎，而且确实不太连贯，坦白说，我家人处理这件事的方式就是从来不谈论它。我的意思是，我可以想象在某种程度上这一定非常痛苦，即使是回忆这些事件也一定非常痛苦，也许他们担心你还很小，和你谈论一些痛苦的事情
might have hurt you. So I can imagine that those might have been the the impulses that caused people to say let's not talk about it. I think that is part of it and I want to come back to that. I think for my family that was definitely part of it. The other part of it was just frankly my grandmother's personality. So she went through a lot of hard times and her way of dealing with it with all of it was let's we just don't revisit that. We just don't go back there. It's not worth revisiting.
可能会伤害到你。所以我可以想象这可能是导致人们说“我们别谈这个了”的冲动。我认为这是原因的一部分，我想回到这一点。我认为对于我的家庭来说，这绝对是原因的一部分。另一部分坦白说只是我祖母的个性。她经历了很多艰难时期，她处理所有事情的方式就是“我们只是不重提往事”。我们只是不去回想。不值得重提。
Quite frankly, when I would ask her questions about her past, my past, my family's past, the answer was always, why do you need to know that? It's over. It's past. In time, Robin would come to study the role that family stories play in the psychological well-being of both children and their caregivers. But that was much later. As a child, Robin wasn't comparing what happened in her family to what happened in other families.
坦白说，当我问她关于她的过去、我的过去、我家人的过去的问题时，答案总是：“你为什么要了解那个？都结束了。那是过去的事了。”随着时间的推移，Robin 开始研究家庭故事在儿童及其照顾者的心理健康中所扮演的角色。但那是很久以后的事了。小时候，Robin 并没有将她家庭发生的事情与别人家庭发生的事情进行比较。
I didn't really notice it until I met my first husband's family. And I started to spend a lot of time with them. And they were a huge family, a family storytelling family. They told stories like many, many families all the time. But they had all the kinds of family stories. They had the everyday, tell me about your day to day, what happened, sharing their home.
直到我遇到第一任丈夫的家庭，我才真正注意到这一点。我开始花很多时间与他们在一起。他们是一个大家庭，一个讲故事的家庭。他们像许多许多家庭一样，一直在讲故事。但他们拥有各种各样的家庭故事。他们有日常的，比如“告诉我你今天过得怎么样，发生了什么”，分享他们的家。
Remember this is like when we went to the beach last summer. And they had the big iconic stories. Every Thanksgiving, every Thanksgiving, the story about how one of the uncles crashed the car through the trees when he was a teenager had to get told. And it had to get told the same way, with the same punch lines every year. And I started to realize how important that was to keep that family cemented as a happy, healthy family. Yeah. Yes, it's not the information in that uncle car crash story that was important because
“还记得去年夏天我们去海滩的时候吗？”他们还有那些标志性的经典故事。每年感恩节，每年感恩节，关于其中一位舅舅十几岁时开车撞进树林的故事都必须讲一遍。而且每年都必须以同样的方式、同样的笑点讲出来。我开始意识到，这对于将这个家庭凝聚成一个幸福、健康的家庭是多么重要。是的，没错，那个舅舅车祸故事里的信息并不重要，因为
everybody knew the facts already. Everybody knew every detail of the story. If you told it the wrong way, everybody would correct you. And what went through your heart when you saw that the wrong way, everybody would correct you. And what went through your heart when you saw that? I mean, you must have been happy to be part of this family that had this rich family lore, but was there a part of you that sort of said, that noticed that you didn't have that? I mean, is that how you, was that made aware to you? I think it was obvious. I mean, it was such a contrast that it was so different
每个人都已经知道事实了。每个人都知道故事的每一个细节。如果你讲错了，每个人都会纠正你。当你看到那个……每个人都会纠正你，这在你心里留下了什么？我的意思是，你一定很高兴能成为这个拥有丰富家庭传说的家庭的一员，但你内心深处有没有一部分人注意到你没有这些？我的意思是，你是这样被意识到的吗？我想这很明显。我的意思是，这种对比太强烈了，以至于它太不同了
than the way my family interacted. As Robin became a researcher, she was to learn that family stories are not just family stories. They are much more than dinner table conversation or fodder for Thanksgiving table punch lines. Family stories turn out to play a crucial role in the mental health of the people who tell the stories and the mental health of the people who listen to the stories. They can serve as anchors for identity and self-esteem.
于我家庭的互动方式。随着 Robin 成为一名研究人员，她了解到家庭故事不仅仅是家庭故事。它们远不止是餐桌上的谈话或感恩节餐桌上的笑料。事实证明，家庭故事在讲述故事的人和倾听故事的人的心理健康中起着至关重要的作用。它们可以作为身份认同和自尊的锚点。
Told right, they can change the direction of our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Robin Fiversh is a psychologist at Emory University who studies the way parents and children communicate. Early on in her career, she spent extended amounts of time with families listening to how parents talked with children. I was interested in how families, particularly mothers, talked with their three, four, five-year-old children about the events of the child's life.
如果讲述得当，它们可以改变我们人生的方向。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是 Shankar Vedantam。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是 Shankar Vedantam。Robin Fivush 是埃默里大学的一位心理学家，研究父母和孩子沟通的方式。在她职业生涯的早期，她花了很多时间与家庭在一起，倾听父母如何与孩子交谈。我对家庭，特别是母亲，如何与三、四、五岁的孩子谈论孩子生活中的事件很感兴趣。
So we did a lot of work where we would visit families in their homes and hang out with them and then we would explicitly ask mothers to sit down with their child and talk about some things that have happened, some special occurrences. We gave them very few instructions. And we looked at how the past got reconstructed. And we discovered that this was really an important part of children learning
所以我们做了很多工作，我们会去家庭的家中拜访他们，和他们待在一起，然后我们会明确要求母亲坐下来和孩子谈论一些发生过的事情，一些特殊的经历。我们给他们的指导很少。我们观察过去是如何被重构的。我们发现，这对于孩子学习
how to narrate their own past. And also that it actually helped children increase their ability to remember the past. We found that different mothers do this in different ways and it has a lot of consequences not only for how children remember things but how they feel about themselves. So mothers and children who are more elaborate and detailed in these kinds of early memory conversations have children who have higher self-esteem even very early in development. They also have higher
如何叙述自己的过去确实是一个重要的部分。而且它实际上帮助孩子提高了记忆过去的能力。我们发现不同的母亲以不同的方式做到这一点，这不仅对孩子如何记忆事物，而且对他们如何看待自己都有很多影响。因此，在这些早期记忆对话中更具阐述性和细节性的母亲和孩子，其孩子即使在发育早期也拥有更高的自尊心。他们也有更高的
emotional understanding because so many of the events that we talk about are emotional. So I was talking with my colleague Marshall Duke, talking about the power of these early conversations and how important it was for children to build up their own narrative story, the story of who they are. Marshall's a clinical psychologist, and he said, yeah, that's totally important, but I bet that what's equally important
情感理解力，因为我们谈论的许多事件都是情感性的。所以我当时正在和我的同事 Marshall Duke 交谈，讨论这些早期对话的力量，以及孩子建立自己的叙事故事——关于他们是谁的故事——是多么重要。Marshall 是一位临床心理学家，他说：“是的，这绝对重要，但我敢打赌同样重要的是
is how families talk about the family past, the family history. Coming from the family idea, I was like, I don't think that matters as much. I really think that that's not as important. So we had this conversation and we were part of a big funded research program. We had the means to do this. We said, let's use our decided to just tape record families talking over the dinner table to see what they talk about.
家庭如何谈论家庭过去，家庭历史。”从家庭理念出发，我当时想，我不认为这有那么重要。我真的认为那没那么重要。所以我们进行了这次谈话，我们是一个大型资助研究项目的一部分。我们有资源来做这件事。我们说，让我们利用我们的……决定只是录下家庭在餐桌上的谈话，看看他们谈论什么。
So we tape recorded these families and we simply asked them to just tape record a few dinner time conversations. We were not there. We just, this is old technology, was literally a physical tape recorder, one of those cassette recorders. Families tell stories all the time. Some reference to a past event occurs every five minutes in a typical Tuesday night spaghetti dinner. Wow. And we know from other research that 40% of all human conversation is referring to past experiences.
所以我们录下了这些家庭的谈话，我们只是简单地要求他们录下几次晚餐时间的谈话。我们不在场。我们只是……这是旧技术，字面上是一个物理录音机，那种盒式录音机之一。家庭一直在讲故事。在一个典型的周二晚上吃意大利面晚餐时，每五分钟就会出现一次对过去事件的引用。哇。我们从其他研究中知道，40% 的人类对话都是在提及过去的经历。
So that's what human beings do. We talk about what happened to us and we ask other people what happened to them. We tell stories, we listen to stories all the time. Most of the stories, and we're talking about, you know, a 35, 40 minute dinner time conversation, most of the stories are what are called today I stories. So most of these table conversations were four, five people. So you're coming back together at the end of the day and you want to weave yourself back together as a family. So a lot of it is, tell me about your day, what happened? And you know, we got what we expected. How was your math test? Did you know, did you make up with Jenny after
所以这就是人类所做的。我们谈论发生在我们身上的事情，我们问别人发生了什么。我们讲故事，我们一直在听故事。大多数故事，我们谈论的是，你知道，一场 35 到 40 分钟的晚餐谈话，大多数故事被称为“今天我”的故事。所以这些餐桌谈话大多是四五个人。所以你在一天结束时重新聚在一起，你想把作为家庭的自己重新编织在一起。所以很多是，“告诉我你的一天，发生了什么？”你知道，我们得到了我们预期的结果。“你的数学考试怎么样？”“你知道，你和 Jenny 和好了吗？”
your fight yesterday? But what also surprised us is that the parents also talked about their day with their children. They talked about what happened at work or what happened in their social life. So they're starting to open up the world for their teenagers. This is what an adult world looks like. This is the world you're going to be developing into, right? It's not just your perspective on the world. I'm telling you stories about my world. So it's really opening
“你昨天的争吵？”但同样让我们惊讶的是，父母也和孩子谈论他们的一天。他们谈论工作中发生的事情或社交生活中发生的事情。所以他们开始为他们的青少年打开世界。这就是成人世界的样子。这就是你将要发展的世界，对吧？这不仅仅是你对世界的看法。我正在告诉你关于我的世界的故事。所以它真的在打开
the world up for them. So that's a lot of it. But then about a third of the stories are these family stories, where the family is talking about something is said and somebody says, and it's just as frequently the child as the parent. That's like when we went to grandma's last Thanksgiving, and then they start talking about that. Or that's like when we went to see Jaws. And embedded in those conversations, you get family history, where parents will start talking about when they were children, or their grandparents' lives.
世界给他们。所以这占了很大一部分。但大约三分之一的故事是这些家庭故事，家庭在谈论某事，有人说——而且孩子和父母一样频繁——“那就像我们去年感恩节去奶奶家的时候”，然后他们就开始谈论那个。或者“那就像我们去看《大白鲨》的时候”。在这些对话中，你会得到家庭历史，父母会开始谈论他们小时候的事情，或者他们祖父母的生活。
And then it turns out the families that told more of these everyday stories were in fact doing better. But what really predicted good functioning both for the family and for the child were the family stories. So in other words, can you talk a little bit about that when you say that the fact that children were doing better, they had better well-being. How so? So families that tell more stories show more trust and community within the family. Then specific to the child, children within families that tell more of these stories, and particularly tell them in a certain way, and I do want to come back to that, have higher self-esteem, they have higher academic competence, they're doing better in school. They have higher social competence.
事实证明，讲述更多这些日常故事的家庭确实做得更好。但真正预测家庭和孩子良好功能的是家庭故事。所以换句话说，当你提到孩子做得更好、他们有更好的幸福感时，你能谈谈吗？怎么说呢？所以讲述更多故事的家庭在家庭内部表现出更多的信任和社区感。然后具体到孩子，在讲述更多这些故事的家庭中的孩子，特别是以某种方式讲述它们——我确实想回到这一点——拥有更高的自尊心，他们有更高的学术能力，他们在学校表现更好。他们有更高的社交能力。
They are more socially skilled. And in later research, because of course we followed up on this first study with lots and lots of research, as they get older and you can start to assess more mature aspects of wellbeing, like a sense of agency, a sense of maturity, a sense of meaning and purpose in life. All of that is higher for children and adolescents and young adults who know more of these family stories. So, as you were probing the relationship between these family stories and well-being, including
他们更具社交技巧。在后来的研究中——因为我们当然用大量的研究跟进了这项初步研究——随着他们长大，你可以开始评估幸福感的更成熟方面，比如能动性、成熟感、生活意义和目标感。对于了解更多这些家庭故事的儿童、青少年和年轻人来说，所有这些都更高。所以，当你探索这些家庭故事与幸福感之间的关系时，包括
long-term well-being, you and a colleague created an instrument called the Do You Know Scale. What does this tool do, Robin, and what are some of the kinds of questions you have on it? The Do You Know Scale is a 20-item yes-no questionnaire that Marshall Duke and I developed simply to assess as a very, very rough index the extent to which families talk about their shared and family history. We ask adolescents and young adults, do you know where your parents met?
长期幸福感，你和一位同事创建了一个名为“你知道吗量表”(Do You Know Scale) 的工具。Robin，这个工具是做什么的，你上面有哪些类型的问题？“你知道吗量表”是一个 20 项的是非问卷，Marshall Duke 和我开发它只是为了作为一个非常、非常粗略的指标来评估家庭谈论他们共享和家庭历史的程度。我们问青少年和年轻人：“你知道你父母在哪里认识的吗？”
Do you know where your mother went to school? Do you know what sports your father played in high school? Do you know where your grandmother grew up? Do you know what school your grandmother went to? Do you know how your grandparents met? So we're not getting stories. We're just getting yes, no. But in order to answer yes to a question like that,
“你知道你母亲在哪里上学吗？”“你知道你父亲在高中参加什么运动吗？”“你知道你祖母在哪里长大的吗？”“你知道你祖母上什么学校吗？”“你知道你祖父母是怎么认识的吗？”所以我们得到的不是故事。我们只是得到“是”或“否”。但为了回答像这样的问题时说“是”，
we're making the assumption you must have been told these stories. And it turns out it's a pretty good assessment of it in two ways. One, this very simple 20 questions, yes, no, is a good index. It relates to self-esteem, agency, meaning and purpose in life, emotional competence. So there's something that this is tapping into that's meaningful. There was one question on the do you know scale that I found very striking. It's do you know about a relative whose face froze in a grumpy position because he or she did not smile enough? What was the point of asking that question, Robin? Marshall and I are both of Jewish heritage. And this, I think, is something that is culturally Jewish.
我们假设你一定被告知过这些故事。事实证明，它在两个方面是一个相当不错的评估。第一，这 20 个简单的是非题是一个很好的指标。它与自尊、能动性、生活意义和目标、情感能力有关。所以这触及了一些有意义的东西。“你知道吗量表”上有一个问题我发现非常引人注目。那就是：“你知道一个亲戚，因为他或她笑得不够多，脸僵硬成了一个暴躁的表情吗？”Robin，问那个问题的意义是什么？Marshall 和我都是犹太血统。我认为这在文化上是犹太人的东西。
We both grew up with caregivers, parents or grandparents, who would say to us when we would cry or scowl, be careful, your Aunt Linda cried all the time and her face froze in that position. And we both had that story. So when we were thinking about family stories, it was kind of an inside joke, to be honest. So we ended up just tagging it on to the end of the questionnaire. But we get asked about that question more than any other question.
我们俩都是在照顾者、父母或祖父母的陪伴下长大的，当我们哭泣或皱眉时，他们会告诉我们：“小心点，你的琳达阿姨总是哭，她的脸就僵在那儿了。”我们俩都有那个故事。所以当我们思考家庭故事时，老实说，这算是一个内部笑话。所以我们最终只是把它加到了问卷的末尾。但被问到那个问题的次数比任何其他问题都多。
So one of the things that you pointed out, and I think is important to underline, is that the key here is not just the knowing of stories in an informational sense, but you discovered there was something powerful about the process of family storytelling. Can you talk about this idea, Robin, that what happens that the important thing here is not the facts, but in some ways the process by which those facts are arrived at? Absolutely. The key here is storytelling, not just stories. So yes, it's important that we know the stories, but the process of learning those stories, hearing those
所以你指出的其中一点，我认为很重要的一点是，这里的关键不仅仅是在信息意义上知道故事，你发现家庭讲故事的过程本身有一些强大的东西。Robin，你能谈谈这个观点吗？即这里重要的事情不是事实，而是在某种程度上达成这些事实的过程？绝对是。这里的关键是讲故事，而不仅仅是故事。所以是的，知道故事很重要，但学习这些故事的过程，听到这些
stories, sharing those stories, learning those stories, hearing those stories, sharing those stories, constructing those stories together is what really is important in terms of this positive youth outcome. So when telling family stories, you said that adults might be modeling the regulation and modulation of emotion, and in some ways children are learning from this. How so, Robin? I think both when we're constructing stories, helping children understand their own experiences, or when we're talking with children about our experiences, the way that we talk about our emotions
故事，分享这些故事，学习这些故事，听到这些故事，分享这些故事，共同构建这些故事，对于这种积极的青年成果来说才是真正重要的。所以当讲述家庭故事时，你说成年人可能是在模拟情绪的调节和调整，在某种程度上孩子正在从中学习。Robin，怎么说呢？我认为无论是当我们构建故事、帮助孩子理解他们自己的经历时，还是当我们与孩子谈论我们的经历时，我们谈论情绪的方式
and how we reacted in the moment, and how we dealt with that emotional reaction helps children understand appropriate emotional regulation. That's a very abstract sentence. Let me give you a sense of what I mean by that. One of the really important things about reminiscing about the child's own emotional experiences is, you know, the child's own emotional experiences is you know the child throws a tantrum in the supermarket and that's the worst time to try and sit down and have you know a calm conversation with them you just want to get out of the situation but then later when the child calms down it's
以及我们在那一刻的反应，以及我们如何处理那种情绪反应，都有助于孩子理解适当的情绪调节。这是一个非常抽象的句子。让我让你感受一下我的意思。关于回忆孩子自己的情感经历，非常重要的一点是，你知道，孩子自己的情感经历是，你知道孩子在超市里发脾气，那是试图坐下来和他们进行冷静谈话的最糟糕时机，你只想离开那个情况，但后来当孩子冷静下来时，
important to sit down and say let let's talk about what happened. You know, why were you so upset? And not to say that was bad, you were wrong, but what happened? You know, why were you upset? Okay, I understand why that upset you, but maybe being that upset was not the best way to get what they wanted. And to help them figure out how to recognize their emotions and resolve them and regulate them.
坐下来谈谈发生了什么很重要。你知道，“你为什么那么难过？”不是说“那很糟糕，你错了”，而是“发生了什么？”你知道，“你为什么难过？”“好吧，我明白为什么那让你难过，但也许那样难过并不是得到他们想要的东西的最佳方式。”并帮助他们找出如何识别自己的情绪、解决它们并调节它们。
So in other words, the story is helping you name the emotion to understand how it came about, to understand what options you might have had in the moment. So it's allowing you in some ways to recreate the event in some ways and ask how could you maybe have reacted differently. I could not have said that better. And when parents tell stories about their own childhood, they're of course not talking about
所以换句话说，故事在帮助你命名情绪，理解它是如何产生的，理解你在那一刻可能有什么选择。所以它在某种程度上允许你重现事件，并询问你可能如何以不同的方式做出反应。我无法说得更好。当父母讲述他们自己童年的故事时，他们当然不是在谈论
their child's emotional reaction. But often those stories are told in moments where the kids are struggling with something. So the parent's story becomes, well, okay, let me tell you how I dealt with something like that in my life and the lesson I took from it. Maybe that will help you think about your life. They're world views. Stories are little models of the world.
他们孩子的情绪反应。但这些故事通常是在孩子们在某些事情上挣扎时讲述的。所以父母的故事变成了：“好吧，让我告诉你我是如何在我的生活中处理类似事情的，以及我从中吸取的教训。也许这会帮助你思考你的生活。”它们是世界观。故事是世界的小模型。
You found, Robin, that the way in which people tell these family stories is really important, and you've identified two common styles that parents use when telling family stories. What are these two styles? So some parents, some families, are very collaborative or collaborative. So I'll give you an example. It's a very simple example. This is actually one of my favorite Conversations was it between a mother and her eight-year-old child and they've gone to Callaway Gardens, which is a recreational beautiful garden near here. They've been on a long bike trip and The child I'll call her, was riding on the handlebars
Robin，你发现人们讲述这些家庭故事的方式非常重要，你确定了父母在讲述家庭故事时使用的两种常见风格。这两种风格是什么？所以一些父母，一些家庭，是非常协作的。所以我给你举个例子。这是一个非常简单的例子。这实际上是我最喜欢的对话之一，发生在一位母亲和她八岁的孩子之间，他们去了卡拉威花园 (Callaway Gardens)，那是这里附近一个美丽的休闲花园。他们进行了一次长途自行车旅行，那个孩子——我叫她 Rebecca——坐在母亲自行车的车把上。
of the mother's bike. And the mother was a bit of a daredevil and Rebecca was a little scared because her mother was kind of going a little wild. And her mother is saying, you know, oh, it's so much fun, you know, rushing down those cobblestones. And Rebecca was saying, yeah, I was a little scared. And the mother, they both laugh. So they're not laughing at Rebecca. They're laughing together. The mother says, yeah, you were a little scared. Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
母亲有点大胆，Rebecca 有点害怕，因为她母亲骑得有点疯狂。母亲说：“你知道，哦，太有趣了，你知道，在那些鹅卵石路上疾驰。”Rebecca 说：“是的，我有点害怕。”母亲，她们都笑了。所以她们不是在嘲笑 Rebecca。她们是在一起笑。母亲说：“是的，你有点害怕。也许我不该那样做。”
And then, what else do you remember about it? And Rebecca says, oh, I was getting so tired. And I wanted to be home. And the mother confirms, yes, I was getting so tired and you know, I wanted to be home and the mother like confirms It's like yes, it was a long day And you know what we had but they're laughing and they're having a good time and at the end the mother says We have a good time together. Don't we and Rebecca says yes we do So they had different perspectives on that event Rebecca may not have had as much fun as her mother But they kind of come to an agreement that they enjoy being together and
“然后，你还记得关于它的什么？”Rebecca 说：“哦，我变得太累了。我想回家。”母亲确认说：“是的，我变得太累了，你知道，我想回家。”母亲确认了，就像“是的，那是漫长的一天，你知道我们有……”但她们在笑，她们玩得很开心，最后母亲说：“我们在一起玩得很开心，不是吗？”Rebecca 说：“是的，我们是。”所以她们对那个事件有不同的看法。Rebecca 可能没有她母亲玩得那么开心，但她们达成了一种共识，即她们喜欢在一起，并且
That they accept each other for who they are Yeah, and they're constructing the story together even though in fact, they don't exactly have the same story They don't have the same memory Yeah exactly have the same story. They don't have the same memory. Yeah, but they're putting the two memories together and in some ways coming up with something that is a collaborative shared memory. Absolutely. And we see that even in the larger families when it's a whole family together. And this is also really particularly important. I mean obviously it's important to talk about the fun times, the positive events, laughing, creating those bonds, obviously it's important to talk about the fun times, the positive events, laughing,
她们接受彼此的本来面目。是的，她们正在共同构建故事，即使事实上，她们并没有完全相同的故事。她们没有相同的记忆。是的，完全没有相同的记忆。是的，但她们把两个记忆放在一起，在某种程度上想出了一些协作的共享记忆。绝对是。即使在大家庭中，当整个家庭在一起时，我们也看到了这一点。这也是特别重要的。我的意思是，显然谈论有趣的时光、积极的事件、欢笑、建立那些纽带很重要，显然谈论有趣的时光、积极的事件、欢笑、
creating those bonds. But it's also important to talk about the challenging experiences. Like I mentioned, having a temper tantrum, if you never talk about it, the child never learns what to do with that emotion the next time it happens. We asked families to talk about challenging experiences. Many of them talked about an illness or death, death of a grandparent or a beloved family pet. And the families that were more collaborative,
建立那些纽带很重要。但谈论具有挑战性的经历也很重要。就像我提到的，发脾气，如果你从不谈论它，孩子就永远不会学会在下一次发生时该怎么处理那种情绪。我们要求家庭谈论具有挑战性的经历。他们中的许多人谈论了疾病或死亡，祖父母或心爱的家庭宠物的死亡。而那些更具协作性的家庭，
who really shared the emotional experience, I know that you were really sad about that, I was sad too. I remember that you were crying when Suzy came over to hug you. And that kind of shared emotional resonance really helps us deal with grief and mourning and difficult experiences. There's also a second style of storytelling that you studied, Robin, and you call this a repetitive style of storytelling. What is the style?
那些真正分享情感体验的家庭，“我知道你对此真的很伤心，我也很伤心。我记得当 Suzy 过来拥抱你时你在哭。”那种共享的情感共鸣确实帮助我们处理悲伤、哀悼和困难的经历。Robin，你还研究了第二种讲故事的风格，你称之为重复式的讲故事风格。这种风格是什么？
What does it look like? So, rather than being asking open-ended questions, you ask close-ended questions. Did you have fun, rather than how did you feel? And that there's no opportunity for the child to do more than say yes or no. Or even saying something like, you remember your grandmother's cookies, don't you? You know, maybe that's not always important to the child. Maybe she wants to talk about the ornaments that were on the Christmas tree. So it's not really giving the child an opportunity to recall their perspective on the event
它看起来是什么样的？所以，与其提出开放式问题，你提出封闭式问题。“你玩得开心吗？”而不是“你感觉如何？”而且孩子没有机会做除了说“是”或“否”之外的事情。或者甚至说像“你记得你祖母的饼干，对吧？”你知道，也许这对孩子来说并不总是重要的。也许她想谈论圣诞树上的装饰品。所以它并没有真正给孩子一个机会来回忆他们对事件的看法
or what they remember. And when the child doesn't remember, the parent will simply repeat the question. Who drove down to Florida with us? Who was in the front seat? Don't you remember? Who was in the front seat with us? And the child just doesn't remember
或者他们记得什么。当孩子不记得时，父母会简单地重复这个问题。“谁开车带我们去佛罗里达的？谁坐在前座？你不记得了吗？谁和我们坐在前座？”而孩子就是不记得
so it's almost as if the elaborative collaborative style is Their their goals are different their goals are to create a shared story in the moment that creates a resonance in a shared history and helps us to bond and understand each other. The more non-elaborative or repetitive parents, it's about getting the facts right. I remember this is a mother with her four-year-old son who was a dinosaur fanatic.
所以这几乎就像阐述性协作风格是……他们的目标不同，他们的目标是在当下创造一个共享的故事，创造一种共鸣和共享的历史，并帮助我们建立联系和相互理解。那些非阐述性或重复性的父母，重点是把事实搞对。我记得这是一位母亲和她四岁的儿子，他是一个恐龙狂热者。
They were talking about going to a natural history museum. She was asking about seeing the T-Rex. He was like, no, there was no T-Rex. She was like, yes, there was. There was a T-Rex there. Don't you remember? And she goes on and says, you know, and then we saw, you know, the exhibit on this dinosaur and that dinosaur. And he's like, yeah, there was a brontosaurus and da da da da. And he lists them, he says, but there was no T-Rex. And she's saying, I know there was a T-Rex. And then he says, no.
他们正在谈论去自然历史博物馆。她问关于看霸王龙的事。他就像，“不，没有霸王龙。”她就像，“有的，有的。那里有一只霸王龙。你不记得了吗？”她继续说，“你知道，然后我们看了，你知道，关于这只恐龙和那只恐龙的展览。”他就像，“是的，有一只雷龙，哒哒哒哒。”他列举了它们，他说，“但没有霸王龙。”她说，“我知道有一只霸王龙。”然后他说，“不。”
And he names another museum. And she says, oh, that's right. But it was almost as if there was a T-Rex there. So it's not a collaboration of, oh, maybe there wasn't. Maybe my memory could not be accurate, or maybe the way you're remembering it is different or you know there's kind of an assumption that I remember it correctly and you don't and it's my job to make sure you remember it correctly. I asked Robin why she thought families with collaborative styles of storytelling function better than families that told stories in order to get the facts right, or families that didn't
他提到了另一个博物馆。她说，“哦，那是对的。”但几乎就像那里有一只霸王龙一样。所以这不是一种协作，比如“哦，也许没有。也许我的记忆可能不准确，或者也许你记住它的方式不同，或者你知道，有一种假设是我记得很正确，而你没有，我的工作是确保你记得很正确。”我问 Robin，为什么她认为具有协作性讲故事风格的家庭比那些为了把事实搞对而讲故事的家庭，或者那些根本不讲故事的家庭功能更好。
tell stories at all. We create our sense of self through our sense of our experiences. I am the person I am because I've had these experiences. This has made me the person I am today. This has set up my beliefs, my goals, my values. Particularly in adolescence and young adulthood, when we really, all of us go through a period of identity questioning, right? As children, we don't question our family's values, their religious values, their community
我们通过我们的经历感来创造我们的自我感。我是现在的我，因为我有过这些经历。这使我成为了今天的我。这确立了我的信仰、我的目标、我的价值观。特别是在青春期和成年早期，当我们所有人确实都经历一个身份质疑的时期时，对吧？作为孩子，我们不质疑家庭的价值观、他们的宗教价值观、他们的社区
values, their moral values. But then we get to an age where we have more resources, we're moving out into the world. We have a greater set of friends and contacts, we can think about things more abstractly. We start to go through what Eric Erickson called the identity crisis. Who am I? Who do I want to be? abstractly, we start to go through what Eric Erickson called the identity crisis. Who am I? Who do I want to be? You know, just because my parents go to church, do I want to go to church? Just because my parents vote for this political party, is that my political party? Many, many adolescents and young adults end up in
价值观、他们的道德价值观。但后来我们到了一个年龄，我们有更多的资源，我们正在走向世界。我们有更多的朋友和联系，我们可以更抽象地思考事情。我们开始经历 Eric Erickson 所说的“身份危机”。我是谁？我想成为谁？抽象地，我们开始经历 Eric Erickson 所说的“身份危机”。我是谁？我想成为谁？你知道，仅仅因为我父母去教堂，我就想去教堂吗？仅仅因为我父母投票给这个政党，那就是我的政党吗？许多许多青少年和年轻人最终
the same place as their parents, But we all go through that process of exploration and questioning. And that's when we really start to put together what's called a life story or a life narrative. How did I become the person I am? And who do I want to be? In doing that, we need material. We certainly have our own experiences, but what we've discovered
和他们的父母在同一个地方，但我们都经历了那个探索和质疑的过程。那就是我们真正开始拼凑所谓的“人生故事”或“人生叙事”的时候。我如何成为现在的我？我想成为谁？在做这件事时，我们需要材料。我们当然有自己的经历，但我们发现
is that adolescents and young adults really draw from their parents' stories, the stories their parents tell them about their childhoods and their family history, to figure out what their own personal experiences mean and how to make sense of it. It's how they draw their life lessons and moral stances. An interesting finding from your research, Robin, is that knowing family stories appears to help people be more resilient in the face of adversity. And you say this might be because hearing other people's
青少年和年轻人确实从他们父母的故事中汲取素材——他们父母讲述的关于他们童年和家庭历史的故事——来弄清楚他们自己的个人经历意味着什么，以及如何理解它。这就是他们汲取人生教训和道德立场的方式。Robin，你研究的一个有趣发现是，了解家庭故事似乎能帮助人们在面对逆境时更具韧性。你说这可能是因为听到别人的
struggles provides us with something that you call vicarious memory. in the face of adversity. And you say this might be because hearing other people's struggles provides us with something that you call vicarious memory. What is vicarious memory? A vicarious memory is a memory that you have of something that happened to somebody else. So I can tell you, for example, I can tell you a story that happened to my husband
挣扎为我们提供了你所说的“替代性记忆”。在面对逆境时。你说这可能是因为听到别人的挣扎为我们提供了你所说的“替代性记忆”。什么是替代性记忆？替代性记忆是你对发生在别人身上的事情的记忆。所以我可以告诉你，例如，我可以告诉你一个发生在我丈夫身上的故事
when he was a child. I wasn't there. I didn't know him when he was a child. I wasn't there. I didn't know him when he was a child. But he's told me that story. I know that story. And so I have a vicarious memory of it. That's what these intergenerational narratives are. Most of our knowledge of the world is vicarious memories essentially provide models or
当他还是个孩子的时候。我当时不在场。我认识他的时候他不是个孩子。我当时不在场。我认识他的时候他不是个孩子。但他告诉过我那个故事。我知道那个故事。所以我对它有替代性记忆。这就是这些代际叙事。我们对世界的大部分了解本质上是替代性记忆，它们提供了模型或
views of how the world works. So when we have these stories of our parents and our family, they become ways of understanding both how the world works and how we fit into that world. One of your studies looked at how children coped following the 9-11 attacks with specific attention to the role of the family stories being told. Tell me about that study and what you found. What we discovered is that the families who had been able to talk more openly and in more
关于世界如何运作的观点。所以当我们有这些关于我们父母和家庭的故事时，它们就成了理解世界如何运作以及我们如何融入那个世界的方式。你的研究之一观察了孩子们在 9-11 袭击后如何应对，特别关注所讲述的家庭故事的作用。告诉我那个研究以及你发现了什么。我们发现，那些能够在 9-11 之前更开放、更
collaborative ways about difficult and challenging experiences pre-9-11 had kids post 9-eleven who were showing better Aspects of well-being they were showing fewer behavior problems fewer indexes of depression less anxiety fewer symptoms like anger problems substance abuse So there was something about being in a collaborative storytelling family that buffered them against some of the anxiety that we all experienced after 9-11.
以协作方式谈论困难和挑战性经历的家庭，其孩子在 9-11 之后表现出更好的幸福感方面。他们表现出更少的行为问题、更少的抑郁指标、更少的焦虑、更少的症状，如愤怒问题、药物滥用。所以，身处一个协作性讲故事的家庭，在某种程度上缓冲了他们在 9-11 之后我们所有人都经历的一些焦虑。
There was another study conducted by the psychologist Adam Brown of the New School that looked at how familiarity with family stories affects military veterans. What did he find, Robin? So as you might imagine, military veterans who have seen combat come home and it's very very difficult for them to talk about their experiences for multiple reasons. One, they themselves are traumatized. They don't want to traumatize their listeners. And frankly, their listeners don't always encourage wanting to hear about the awful things that had to happen. We saw this with World War II vets, Holocaust survivors. It's a general pattern of people who have experienced trauma. We see it with refugee families.
新学院的心理学家亚当·布朗进行了另一项研究，探讨了对家庭故事的熟悉程度如何影响退伍军人。罗宾，他发现了什么？正如你所料，经历过战斗的退伍军人回到家后，由于多种原因，他们很难谈论自己的经历。第一，他们自己受到了创伤。他们不想让听众也受到创伤。坦率地说，听众并不总是鼓励他们讲述那些不得不发生的糟糕事情。我们在二战老兵和纳粹大屠杀幸存者身上看到了这一点。这是经历过创伤的人的一种普遍模式。我们在难民家庭中也看到了这一点。
But the veterans who came home having experienced traumatic combat in Iraq and Afghanistan, the ones who knew more of their family history showed higher levels of adjustment and well-being than those who did not. And again it's some suggestion that having that as a buffer is helpful and I think it's because that tells you we are a family that perseveres. We've been through hard times. We've gotten through them. We stay together. We get through it.
但是，那些在伊拉克和阿富汗经历过创伤性战斗后回家的退伍军人，如果他们了解更多的家庭历史，比起那些不了解的人，表现出了更高水平的适应能力和幸福感。这再次表明，拥有这种缓冲是有帮助的，我认为这是因为它告诉你，我们是一个坚韧的家庭。我们经历过艰难时期。我们挺过来了。我们团结一致。我们度过了难关。
In one of the stories that you elicited from one of your research participants, a 14-year-old named Mary, she told you about a story involving her grandfather and her father. Tell me that story, Robin. This was an African-American family, and it shows how family stories can situate us not only in a family history, but in world history. So this is a story about the Civil Rights Movement and about this family's role in the Civil Rights Movement. So Mary told us this story that her father,
在你从研究参与者那里收集到的故事中，有一个14岁的女孩叫玛丽，她给你讲了一个关于她祖父和父亲的故事。罗宾，讲讲那个故事吧。这是一个非裔美国人家庭，它展示了家庭故事如何不仅能让我们置身于家庭历史中，还能让我们置身于世界历史中。这是一个关于民权运动以及这个家庭在民权运动中所扮演角色的故事。玛丽告诉我们，她的父亲，
when he was in a stroller, was taken to a civil rights rally where MLK spoke in Atlanta by his, I think it was by his grandparents. And he still remembers it even though he was so young, he was in a stroller. And according to the story, it really changed his perception of the world. He felt validated and it was the awakening of his political consciousness. Now, is that possible? Probably not if he was in a stroller, but it's still a great story. And Mary herself used that story to talk about her own interest and work in political activism. So when Mary tells that story of her father in a stroller listening to the Reverend Martin Luther King Jr., what she's saying is, that is my story as well.
在他还是个婴儿时，被他的祖父母（我想是祖父母）带去参加了马丁·路德·金在亚特兰大发表讲话的民权集会。尽管他当时还很小，坐在婴儿车里，但他仍然记得。根据这个故事，它确实改变了他对世界的看法。他感到被认可，这是他政治意识的觉醒。现在，这可能吗？如果他当时在婴儿车里，可能不太可能，但这仍然是一个很棒的故事。玛丽本人用这个故事来谈论她自己对政治行动主义的兴趣和工作。所以，当玛丽讲述她父亲坐在婴儿车里听马丁·路德·金牧师演讲的故事时，她想表达的是，那也是我的故事。
That is my story, not just of me and my family, but of my people. You found that when young people tell family stories from the perspective of a parent or an ancestor. This can have very powerful effects. You once heard a story from a 14-year-old named Dave who told you a story about his mother when she was in high school. What was the story? Dave was 14 and he talked about this story where his mother was also in junior high or middle school and she was at the school bus stop and she overheard one kid bullying this other little boy. And she went up to him and this is the story that Dave tells.
那是我的故事，不仅是我和我的家庭的故事，也是我族人的故事。你发现，当年轻人从父母或祖先的角度讲述家庭故事时，这会产生非常强大的影响。你曾经听过一个叫戴夫的14岁男孩讲过他母亲上高中时的故事。那是什么故事？戴夫14岁时讲了这个故事：他母亲当时也在读初中，她在校车站无意中听到一个孩子欺负另一个小男孩。她走过去对他说——这就是戴夫讲述的故事。
She went up to him and she said, stop bullying that kid. Even though she was really scared herself and was afraid of what the bully would do to her. And the bully said, what's it to you? And she said, it's not right. And so the bully hold off and hit her. And then he comes back. He said, but my mother, you know, she didn't even realize her nose was broken, but she went to the hospital and indeed her nose got broken. And that was just such a courageous thing for my mom to do, to stand up to a bully like that. And the coda of the story, and this is really critical too, is, and it really
她走过去对他说，别欺负那个孩子。尽管她自己也很害怕，担心那个恶霸会对她做什么。那个恶霸说，关你什么事？她说，这不对。于是恶霸停下来打了她。然后他回来了。他说，但我妈妈，你知道，她甚至没意识到自己的鼻子被打断了，但她去了医院，确实鼻子被打断了。我妈妈能那样站出来对抗恶霸，真是太勇敢了。故事的结尾，这一点也非常关键，是，它真的
taught me how important it is to stand up to bullies. So Dave is putting himself in his mother's shoes, in her head. What is she thinking? What is she saying? How is she feeling? And that even though she was scared, she did it anyway. So it really is this lovely model of what it means to be morally courageous. That he's essentially saying, my mother could be courageous when she was 14, I can too. The developmental age matching, I think, is important because every child at age thinks their parent doesn't understand them and never went through anything like this. But this is, she's like me. And of course, parents are
教会了我站出来对抗恶霸是多么重要。所以戴夫把自己放在了他母亲的位置上，进入了她的思想。她在想什么？她在说什么？她感觉如何？尽管她很害怕，但她还是做了。所以这确实是一个关于什么是道德勇气的可爱榜样。他本质上是在说，我妈妈14岁时能勇敢，我也能。我认为这种发展年龄的匹配很重要，因为每个孩子在那个年龄都认为父母不理解他们，从未经历过这样的事情。但事实是，她就像我一样。当然，父母是
identity figures. I'm like her. Stories are not just stories. They are sophisticated tools that humans use to pass on values, norms, and the complex contours of relationships. In family settings, stories can be engines of meaning, identity, and purpose. When we come back, how we can start to tell better stories. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Robin Fyvush is a psychologist at Emory University who studies family stories. She's found that intergenerational storytelling has a wide range of
身份认同的榜样。我像她。故事不仅仅是故事。它们是人类用来传递价值观、规范和复杂人际关系的复杂工具。在家庭环境中，故事可以是意义、身份和目标的引擎。回来后，我们将探讨如何开始讲述更好的故事。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。罗宾·菲武什是埃默里大学研究家庭故事的心理学家。她发现代际讲故事有广泛的
psychological benefits that range from increased resilience to higher self-esteem. Robin, you and your colleague Marshall Duke have theorized that there are three types of family stories and that one of these three is the most predictive of positive outcomes. What are these three types of stories, Robin? Ascending, descending, and oscillating. These are not about particular stories. It's about the shape of the whole family saga, so to speak. So this is really the family history.
心理益处，从增强韧性到提高自尊。罗宾，你和你的同事马歇尔·杜克推测有三种类型的家庭故事，其中一种最能预测积极的结果。这三种故事是什么，罗宾？上升型、下降型和振荡型。这些不是指特定的故事。可以说，它们是指整个家庭传奇的形态。所以这实际上是家庭历史。
So ascending, in some sense, it's the American dream. We came with nothing. We worked hard, and we succeeded. Ta-da! Descending is things are bad, they only got worse, things are never going to get better. And oscillating is life happens. There's good in life, there's bad in life. We will talk about the bad things that happened, but we'll also put them in the context of
上升型，在某种意义上，就是美国梦。我们一无所有地来到这里，我们努力工作，我们成功了。瞧！下降型是事情很糟糕，只会变得更糟，事情永远不会好转。而振荡型是生活总会发生。生活中既有好的，也有坏的。我们会谈论发生的坏事，但我们也会把它们放在
all of the good things that happened. So for example, we came, we worked hard. Unfortunately, we didn't have as much success as we might have liked. There were some back steps that we had to take, but we overcame. And now we are here and we're still together. That's a characterization because all family sagas are a little bit of all of those. But the problem with ascending everything's's great all the time, is it's not. And life happens. And if that's your model, when something bad happens, you have
所有发生的好事的背景下。例如，我们来了，我们努力工作。不幸的是，我们没有取得我们想要的那么大的成功。我们不得不退后几步，但我们克服了。现在我们在这里，我们仍然在一起。这是一种概括，因为所有的家庭传奇都包含这些成分。但上升型的问题在于，一切总是很棒，事实并非如此。生活总会发生。如果这是你的模式，当坏事发生时，你
no resources. You have no, well, I know Grandpa Joe went through something like this and was okay. You have nothing to rely on. So you just have no coping skills. Descending, of course, is this kind of spiraling down into rumination. So the oscillating story is one where you have a sense of life has its ups and downs, but we are a strong persevering family we will overcome. We will get through this. You say that it's really valuable for parents to share stories of their own transgressions with their children. What are these transgression stories and why are they important to share? Transgression stories are stories that really challenge our sense of who we are.
没有任何资源。你没有那种“我知道乔爷爷经历过这样的事情，但他没事”的经验。你没有任何依靠。所以你根本没有应对技巧。下降型，当然，是一种陷入反刍的螺旋式下降。所以振荡型故事是这样一种故事：你意识到生活有起有落，但我们是一个坚强、坚韧的家庭，我们会克服困难。我们会度过难关。你说父母与孩子分享自己的过错故事非常有价值。这些过错故事是什么？为什么分享它们很重要？过错故事是那些真正挑战我们自我认知的挑战。
We did something that we're ashamed of, not proud of, we feel guilty about. We hurt somebody or did something wrong. And we all do it. I mean, hopefully in our lives, small transgressions. We lie, we cheat. Maybe we do a little bit of stealing, or we betray a trust, we break a promise. So for example, we're working with adolescents.
我们做了让我们感到羞耻、不引以为豪、感到内疚的事情。我们伤害了某人或做错了事。我们都会这样做。我的意思是，希望在我们的生活中，只是小过错。我们撒谎，我们作弊。也许我们偷了一点东西，或者我们背叛了信任，我们违背了诺言。例如，我们正在与青少年合作。
So the stories that the parents tell, the transgressions are minor. They cheated on an exam, relatively minor. A lot of them are about lying to their parent or sneaking out. I think sometimes adolescents and young adults think that their parents don't understand what it is to go through teenage angst, don't understand what it is to be angry or dark or moody. But in fact, we all have those memories.
所以父母讲述的故事，那些过错是轻微的。他们在考试中作弊，相对轻微。很多是关于对父母撒谎或偷偷溜出去。我认为有时青少年和年轻人认为他们的父母不理解经历青春期焦虑是什么感觉，不理解愤怒、阴郁或喜怒无常是什么感觉。但事实上，我们都有那些记忆。
And it's one thing to say, oh, well, yes, I felt like that too when I was your age. I think it's another thing when you tell a story like this, it gives it a texture, a reality. It's like, you really were a brat. Wow, you do get it. You get who I am. You get what I'm feeling.
说“哦，是的，我在你这个年纪也有过这种感觉”是一回事。但我认为当你讲这样一个故事时，它赋予了它一种质感，一种真实感。就像是，你真的曾经是个顽童。哇，你真的懂。你懂我是谁。你懂我的感受。
You also say that collecting and saving physical objects can also keep family stories alive. Robin, you treasure an object that connects you to a woman whom you've never met named Annie Lester. What is this object and who was Annie Lester? The object is a diamond engagement ring. So when I married my husband, unfortunately, both of his parents died relatively young and he neither was alive when I met
你还说收集和保存实物也能让家庭故事鲜活起来。罗宾，你珍藏着一件让你与一位从未谋面的女性安妮·莱斯特联系在一起的物品。这件物品是什么？安妮·莱斯特是谁？这件物品是一枚钻石订婚戒指。所以当我嫁给我的丈夫时，不幸的是，他的父母都相对年轻时就去世了，我见到他时他们都不在世了，
him, so I never had the opportunity to meet either one of them. But when we got married, he was able to give me his mother's ring. His mother's name was Annie Lester. And he has a fairly large and very good storytelling family. So I have been enmeshed in stories about Paul, his father, and Annie Lester, his mother. And everybody has these fabulous stories. But I never got a chance to meet them. But through this ring, I feel connected to his mother. And his mother was, she was
所以我从来没有机会见到他们中的任何一个。但当我们结婚时，他能够把母亲的戒指给我。他母亲的名字叫安妮·莱斯特。他有一个相当庞大且非常擅长讲故事的家庭。所以我一直沉浸在关于保罗（他的父亲）和安妮·莱斯特（他的母亲）的故事中。每个人都有这些精彩的故事。但我从来没有机会见到他们。但通过这枚戒指，我感到与他的母亲有了联系。他的母亲，她
a wisp of a woman who was a force of nature. She also was very wild in her teenage years, settled down and was just fiercely loyal to her family, and anybody who did any kind of threatened harm to her family got a lesson from Annie Lester. She had a sharp tongue and wasn't afraid to use it. She was stubborn, but unbelievably loving. And I just love those characteristics. So I feel connected to her,
是一个身材瘦小但充满力量的女性。她在青少年时期也非常狂野，后来安定下来，对家庭极其忠诚，任何威胁到她家庭的人都会从安妮·莱斯特那里得到教训。她说话尖刻，而且不怕使用它。她很固执，但爱得不可思议。我非常喜欢这些特质。所以我感到与她有联系，
even though I've never met her. Stories carry a connection even when that person is no longer there. And that connection for me, with Annie Lester, is a connection of love and compassion so that I can still feel that love and compassion even when the person is no longer there. As you were listening to today's story, you may have found yourself casting your mind back to your own family.
即使我从未见过她。故事即使在人不在时也能承载联系。对我来说，与安妮·莱斯特的这种联系是爱与同情的联系，这样即使人不在了，我仍然能感受到那种爱与同情。当你听今天的故事时，你可能发现自己回想起了自己的家庭。
Did you come from a storytelling family or a taciturn family? Did you notice that some people in your family loved to tell stories, while others didn't see the point of it? In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain+, we explore the complex gender dynamics in family stories. We explore why women tell stories differently than men, and why both men and women tell stories about women differently than stories about men. Robin also shares some specific techniques to elicit from family members the deep, rich,
你来自一个爱讲故事的家庭，还是一个沉默寡言的家庭？你有没有注意到你家里有些人喜欢讲故事，而另一些人觉得没意义？在我们这一集的配套故事中（仅供Hidden Brain+订阅者使用），我们探讨了家庭故事中复杂的性别动态。我们探讨了为什么女性讲故事的方式与男性不同，以及为什么男性和女性讲述关于女性的故事与讲述关于男性的故事时方式不同。罗宾还分享了一些具体技巧，从家庭成员那里引出深刻、丰富、
elaborative stories that seem to predict better mental health and self-esteem, especially for young people. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, How to Bind Your Family Together. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. You can get a free 7-day trial in both places. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes, and stories where listeners ask our favorite guests their own questions.
详尽的故事，这些故事似乎能预测更好的心理健康和自尊，尤其是对年轻人而言。如果你是订阅者，那一集现在就可以收听。标题是《如何凝聚你的家庭》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你可以在这两个地方获得7天的免费试用。你将立即获得我们所有订阅者专享内容的访问权限，包括往期节目，以及听众向我们最喜欢的嘉宾提问的故事。
Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Robin Fivush is a psychologist at Emory University. Robin, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. I really enjoyed it. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns,
再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。罗宾·菲武什是埃默里大学的心理学家。罗宾，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。我真的很喜欢。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·伯恩斯、
Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Today's story comes from Gary Dietz. He wants to thank four unsung heroes who helped him over the span of two hours. Gary's son, Alexander, has a rare genetic condition
安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。今天我们以我们姐妹节目《我未被歌颂的英雄》中的一个故事结束。这个《我未被歌颂的英雄》片段由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助。今天的故事来自加里·迪茨。他想感谢四位在他两小时的困难时刻帮助过他的未被歌颂的英雄。加里的儿子亚历山大患有一种罕见的遗传疾病，
that causes intellectual and behavioral challenges. Some time ago, for Alexander's 24th birthday, Gary and his partner Eileen decided to give Alexander one of his favorite experiences, a walk around Boston. On a warm fall day, the three of them drove from their home in New Hampshire to Charlestown, Massachusetts. From there, they got on the ferry to Boston's North End.
导致智力和行为方面的挑战。前段时间，为了亚历山大的24岁生日，加里和他的伴侣艾琳决定给亚历山大一个他最喜欢的体验：在波士顿散步。在一个温暖的秋日，他们三人从新罕布什尔州的家中开车前往马萨诸塞州的查尔斯顿。从那里，他们乘渡轮前往波士顿的北区。
And when we got on the ferry, my first unsung hero of the day was actually the woman taking tickets on the ferry. It was a very crowded and beautiful day, and she could see that there was something slightly amiss with Alexander. He seemed very nervous, and I thought that was extremely perceptive and compassionate of her. And while we were waiting online, the woman taking the tickets just waved us by. It was a very subtle thing to do, and it made the ferry ride a little bit more bearable. After they got off the ferry, they found a restaurant. Alexander seemed fine, so they went inside. But right after they ordered, Alexander started to get agitated, and soon he was having a
当我们登上渡轮时，我当天的第一位未被歌颂的英雄其实是渡轮上的检票员。那天非常拥挤，天气很好，她能看出亚历山大有些不对劲。他看起来非常紧张，我觉得她非常有洞察力和同情心。当我们排队时，检票的那位女士只是挥手让我们通过。这是一个非常微妙的举动，让渡轮之旅变得稍微容易忍受了一些。下船后，他们找到了一家餐馆。亚历山大看起来还好，所以他们进去了。但就在他们点完餐后，亚历山大开始变得焦躁不安，很快他就出现了
physical meltdown. And this was going to be very challenging within the city because when he has a physical meltdown, he can hurt himself or others and we really shouldn't be in a restaurant. And this hadn't happened when we'd been out really for a few years. So we very quickly asked the bartender, he was a really cool young man, and we had just put our order in and I said, excuse me sir is it too late to cancel our order? And having worked at restaurants when I was a kid, I kind of knew it was probably too late to pull the order,
身体崩溃。这在城市里将是非常具有挑战性的，因为当他身体崩溃时，他可能会伤害自己或他人，我们真的不应该待在餐馆里。而且我们已经好几年没有遇到这种情况了。所以我们很快问了酒保，他是一个非常酷的年轻人，我们刚点完餐，我说，打扰一下，先生，现在取消订单还来得及吗？因为我小时候在餐馆工作过，我知道撤单可能已经太晚了，
but he just waved us off and he said, no problem, I get it. You guys come back another time when things are better for you. And again, this concept of perception and compassion happened a second time that day. They left the restaurant and walked around, hoping Alexander would calm down.
但他只是挥挥手说，没问题，我懂。你们下次情况好点的时候再来。同样，这种洞察力和同情心的概念在那天第二次发生了。他们离开了餐馆，四处走动，希望亚历山大能冷静下来。
Gary decided to call an Uber to get back to that car in Charlestown. As they waited for the Uber, Alexander became more distressed and began to get aggressive. Gary and Eileen had to physically restrain him. And that's when the Uber driver pulled up, a man named Mohammed.
加里决定叫一辆优步回到查尔斯顿的车里。当他们等待优步时，亚历山大变得更加痛苦，并开始变得具有攻击性。加里和艾琳不得不强行控制住他。就在这时，优步司机停了下来，一个叫穆罕默德的人。
Mohammed was completely nonplussed. It was just like a normal thing for him, which I thought that was really weird because when we got in the car, he actually pulled his seat forward, leaned forward, put his hands all the way on the dashboard so that Alexander couldn't grab him. And it was really clear to me that he knew what was going on, which was really surprising, honestly. So he started to drive the Uber and Alexander was still at the height of his meltdown. And the only words really that Muhammad said to us the whole time were in sort of broken English, I have a
穆罕默德完全没有表现出惊讶。对他来说这就像一件平常事，我觉得这真的很奇怪，因为当我们上车时，他实际上把座位向前拉，身体前倾，把手完全放在仪表盘上，这样亚历山大就抓不到他了。我很清楚他知道发生了什么，老实说，这真的很令人惊讶。所以他开始驾驶优步，亚历山大仍然处于崩溃的顶峰。穆罕默德全程对我们说的唯一的话是用一种蹩脚的英语说，我有一个
cousin, same thing, I understand. And at that point was super heroic for me because I was worried that the Uber driver would kick us out because Alexander was being dangerous or that I would be embarrassed or any one of the million feelings that parents of special needs young adults that have challenges experience. But he immediately made me feel as comfortable as I possibly could at that point for the few minute cab ride back to Charlestown where our car was parked. They got out of the car. By this point, all of them were hot and sweaty. Alexander needed water, so they found a cafe and sat down at the patio, but it was about to close. And so I sort of waved to the person
表弟，也是这样，我理解。在那一刻，对我来说这简直是英雄般的行为，因为我担心优步司机会因为亚历山大有危险而把我们赶下车，或者我会感到尴尬，或者特殊需求年轻人的父母经历的数百万种感受中的任何一种。但他立刻让我感到在那几分钟回查尔斯顿停车处的车程中尽可能地舒适。他们下了车。此时，他们所有人都又热又汗。亚历山大需要水，所以他们找到了一家咖啡馆，坐在露台上，但它快要关门了。所以我向里面的人挥了挥手
who was inside the cafe, and she waved back to me, clearly indicating, we're closed, we're closed. And I try to make signs there that, you know, I know you're closed, but I really need your help. Can you come out? And after a few seconds, she sort of caught onto the context. She brought them some ice water. Gary rubbed it on Alexander's head to help cool him down
咖啡馆里的人，她也向我挥手，清楚地表示，我们关门了，我们关门了。我试图在那里打手势，你知道，我知道你们关门了，但我真的需要你们的帮助。你能出来吗？几秒钟后，她明白了情况。她给他们拿了一些冰水。加里把它擦在亚历山大的头上帮他降温，
while Eileen went to get the car. By the time she came back, Alexander was finally getting back to his normal self. He gave us a hug and a handshake, which is the way he indicates that he's calmed down, and we were ready to drive back to New Hampshire. Eileen and I were a mess, but the only thing we could really talk about that made us feel better
而艾琳去取车。当她回来时，亚历山大终于恢复了正常。他给了我们一个拥抱和握手，这是他表示冷静下来的方式，我们准备开车回新罕布什尔州。艾琳和我一团糟，但我们唯一能谈论的让我们感觉好一点的事情
were these four people that really showed that situational awareness, that compassion, that ability to really put themselves in our shoes, and that's really why I call them heroes. If Gary could speak directly to his four heroes, this is what he would say. Your grace and helping me and my son in my family in that moment may seem like a little deal to you, but to me it changed It changed our day and also changes ever so slightly my perception of how crappy the world can be sometimes for my son and for the things that we experience with my son. So just because it seemed little to you doesn't mean it wasn't giant for us. So I want to thank you for that.
就是这四个人，他们真正展现了那种情境意识、那种同情心、那种真正设身处地为他人着想的能力，这就是我称他们为英雄的原因。如果加里能直接对他的四位英雄说话，他会这样说。你们在那个时刻帮助我和我儿子以及我的家庭的恩典，对你们来说可能是一件小事，但对我来说，它改变了。它改变了我们的一天，也稍微改变了我对世界有时对我儿子以及我们与我儿子一起经历的事情有多糟糕的看法。所以，仅仅因为它对你们来说看起来很小，并不意味着它对我们来说不是巨大的。所以我为此感谢你们。
Gary Dietz of Brookline, New Hampshire. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. You can find more stories like this on the My Unsung Hero podcast or on our website hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
新罕布什尔州布鲁克莱恩的加里·迪茨。《我未被歌颂的英雄》这一片段由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助。你可以在《我未被歌颂的英雄》播客或我们的网站 hiddenbrain.org 上找到更多这样的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。